yo guys what's up prestige here and
today i'm going to show you the what i
think is the best class and call of duty
ghosts and you don't have to be high
level it's pretty chill and yeah it's
going to do it basically the this entire
class is focused around the MSBs which
is an a three round burst assault rifle
the main reason I choose this is because
it is a two shot at close to medium
range it is two shot and two three round
burst attachments i use our muzzle brake
which increases a lot of stuff and red
dot sight because the iron sights
articulate I don't use the secondaries I
don't think I need it IEDs really good
it's like a c4 Claymore mix that wrecks
and then get no tactful don't need that
and also in the perks this is also
another very key point you have your
sleight of hand you have quick draw and
I think a sculpture I can't really read
it from here and lastly we have dead i
dead I is the big perk you want dead i
makes it so that as you kill somebody
you have a higher chance and healing
more damage and when this guy because
all we already deals so much damage
because that to shot at close to medium
range you're gonna wreck kids Oh with
this perk and the other two perks I just
think our make it easier to run around
and pull people with the other two you
can kind of mess up but that I is
definitely one that you're going to want
to use and kill streak I just run a
soldier standard you can really change
it up not really focusing on that too
much yeah that's basically the class and
let's get right into some gameplay
anything so you had this gun I just it
can dominate people so hard to close
range and I think you'll get to see a
little of get I effect here you saw that
little red part on the cross hairs that
means that one of the shots was a
Deadeye shot so this gun as I said just
the fact that it's called its
overpowered it definitely is an
overpowered gun since you can kill
people in less than a burst you don't
even need to land all the shots of a
single burst and you'll still get the
killing which see I'm gonna miss miss
miss miss
and then the the one burst that I hit
he's just dead now it's definitely an
overpowered gun to better watch out when
you using it you proud you might get a
little heat and I wouldn't suggest using
all the time since hopefully they nerf
it since I don't think it should be this
powerful you just interested I from its
really annoying oh so I'd suggest using
this not as your main class since if you
bank on this the whole time then people
are just one of them when an update
comes and if they do nerf it you're
going to be plumb out of luck because
you're and be banking on that and you
won't have any more so I'd say this is
probably one of the strongest class
setups in the entire game of ghosts as
of now an update will most likely change
that however dead i I'm probably any any
best class like see right there danke
had a shotgun and at close range I
wrecked him because I had the MSPs lust
dead i probably could gentleman was just
the MSBs but yeah that is a pretty
expensive it's 15 to unlock if you're
not level 60 so it's a lot to unlock but
it's definitely worth it and that is
basically it's hope you guys enjoyed
this you didn't make sure you leave like
right come or subscribe and he's a
little IED MSPs dual play
oh my god